as hurricane Irma approaches the United
States southeast Florida's health system
is mobilizing for a surge in demand for
medical care more than a million
Floridians have been told to evacuate
from the path of the storm at least 11
hospitals are being evacuated health
officials warn residents to take action
now to avoid an emergency our dr. David
agus is here good morning so we know
Mercy Hospital Miami evacuated 200
patients and over 140 health facilities
in Florida now closed what are the
implications for people who need care
well personally to get a patient out of
a hospital into another state is very
difficult you have to go by ambulance
and air transport or military transport
then you're talking hundreds of patients
and then 7,000 patients a year visit the
I mean a day visit the emergency room in
southeastern Florida so these are large
numbers and when hospitals are closing
caris turning limited so people need to
get out of the state so what's the
recourse for people who who need
electrical equipment well that's a key
one is that you know tens of thousands
of people the estimate is twenty
thousand people in the area are
dependent on electrical equipment for
their daily life that is oxygen
generators dialysis and others and
that's obviously not going to be there
as the storm hits the shore so those
people need to get out and the problem
is transport if you're an oxygen and
it's going ten miles an hour you're
trying to drive from Miami to Georgia
it's impossible to do so this is a very
complicated procedure where they're
gonna need medical transport and that's
what's happening now I just wanted to
show this scene because it happened
yesterday at a Lowe's where a woman had
driven 30 miles to get a generator there
were no more generators left and this
man who she didn't know said here take
my generator but that just and they just
embraced and hugged for a long time she
was incredibly emotional it just brings
home how dependent people are on
electricity for their care and then you
know the key thing is now take your
medicines put them in a ziploc bag and
take them with you you need weeks of
medicines all too often people go for a
day or two supply but if this goes on
longer like we expect you need your
medicines their pharmacies are opening
up across the country and allowing
prescriptions to be written it's really
critical that you take your medicine and
technology is really helping as well
telemedicine in particular you were
treating patients during Hurricane
Harvey
talk about that and talk about what we
can expect to see out of Florida now I
know it's exciting
many of the telemedicine companies have
stepped up and they're offering their
services for free to patients who live
in the southeastern Florida you know
during the hurricane in Texas you know
many doctors were several called me and
said I'm trying to get my family out can
you deal with my patients and I had a
list of phone calls and two dozen
patients I called them on the phone
helped with their medical care and was
there for them because doctors nurses
emergency care physician they have
families too they have parents they have
children they have to take care of so
it's very difficult yeah we're saying
how useful some of these apps and
technology can really fantastic I guess
thank you so much for joining us